uh you mentioned Stevie Wonder uh Stevie
Wonder's obviously obviously a fan of
yours when you meet Stevie Wonder what
is that like so like I feel like he's
got like one of those people kind of
like Prince they feel like they might
have an aura you see around them for
sure for sure but also very funny such a
jokester such a trickster will say
whatever's on his mind
um I'm like you should let people see
more of this side of you because people
do put he I mean his music is like
holy you know
um he's the blueprint for a lot of a lot
of music
but just to like he was on my last
project dirty computer and um just I
recorded him talking we had just a
conversation and we were just talking
about all the heaviness this is somebody
who's lived in multiple Generations you
know somebody who was here uh
pre-integration and and got a chance to
usher in
um
so revolutions you know with his music
and he just has stories that nobody has
right he probably does there's not a lot
of people who are walking this Earth who
could tell stories like him
yeah just a beautiful spirit and and um
yeah I love him I love him all right so
the album is out everybody go get it age
of pleasure any did we talk about how I
did the album how'd you do it okay so my
friends I was talking about that same
party everyday people they could not
um find a spot and so I offered our spot
Wonderland uh in L.A we have a spot in
Atlanta and now in L.A there's like
creative spaces yeah creative space you
know Studio indoor outdoor Vibes and
um
I offered our spot and I was like let's
do like maybe 100 people
um test everybody is doing the pandemic
and the people who were at the party
again most beautiful brown and black
people from all over the globe from
Africa South Africa Ghana Nigeria
um Jamaica the Caribbeans New York L.A
Midwest like all of us together in a
safe space
and in the pandemic when you hadn't been
around people
reintegrating super weird it was just
like but it was like oh this is life
like this is what we fight to protect
right this is what we're missing that's
what we're missing I don't realize
you're missing it until you're yeah
until you and I was like okay I know I
want to make a soundtrack I want to make
a soundtrack to this lifestyle because I
want to see that Joy you know I
oftentimes our safe spaces
um
are
police come in shut it down and and to
see us having that Joy
complete strangers getting to know each
other feeling so free uh was something
that I I only dream of and I always want
for everybody and so I just started
making the music
for the parties that was it I said until
my DJ don't say it's me I'm gonna make
like two to three songs just play them
in the mix play it and if people are not
shazamming it's not going on the album
if people are going to go sit down it
will not make the album and that's how I
made um the age of pleasure with my
friends for my friends